sabiendo algo que ella ignoraba.
Y era que si en una hora,
nuestro hijo no nacía,
la iba a dejar sola en la cama
para volver al trabajo
y hacerle una presentación sobre IA
a mi jefe, el CEO de Apple.
Por fortuna, mi hija nació a las 11:30...
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
salvándome de hacer lo impensado.
Y hasta este día, siento mucho
que mi ética de trabajo se antepusiera al amor a mi familia.
(Aplausos)
Por otro lado, mi presentación sobre IA salió brillante.
(Risas)
A Apple le encantó mi presentación y decidieron hacerla pública
en TED 1992,
hace 26 años en este mismo escenario.
Creí que había hecho uno de los más grandes descubrimientos en IA
y lo mismo pensó el "Wall Street Journal" al día siguiente.
Pero en lo que respecta a descubrimientos,
resultó que,
no descubrí América o India.
Quizás descubrí algo así como una pequeña isla cerca de Portugal.
Pero la era del descubrimiento para la IA continuó,
y más científicos pusieron alma y corazón en ello.
Hace unos 10 años, el mayor descubrimiento sobre las IAs
lo lograron tres científicos norteamericanos,
y se conoce como aprendizaje profundo.
El aprendizaje profundo es una tecnología que permite usar grandes bases de datos,
dentro de un solo sitio dominio,
y que aprende a decidir o predecir con precisión sobrehumana.
Por ejemplo, si se le muestra a la red de aprendizaje profundo
una cantidad masiva de fotos de comidas,
puede reconocer
cuándo es un "hot dog" y cuándo no lo es.
(Aplausos)
O si le mostramos un sinfín de fotos, vídeos y datos de sensores
sobre cómo conducir en la autopista,
el programa logrará conducir un vehículo en la autopista como un humano.
¿Qué pasaría si le mostráramos a la red de aprendizaje profundo
todos los discursos del presidente Trump?
Entonces, esta IA del presidente Trump,
digo la red...
(Risas)
Podría...
(Aplausos)
Les gustan las contradicciones, ¿verdad?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Si a esta red, le dan la orden de hacer un discurso sobre las IAs,
él, o eso, podría decir algo como...
(Grabación) Donald Trump: Es grandioso
poder construir un mundo mejor usando inteligencia artificial.
Kai-Fu Lee: ¿Y qué tal en otro idioma?
DT: (Hablando en chino)
(Risas)
KFL: No sabían que Trump hablaba chino ¿verdad?
El aprendizaje profundo se ha convertido en el eje central en la era de la IAs,
que va liderada por EE. UU.
Pero ahora estamos en la era de la implementación,
donde lo que prima es la calidad del producto, su ejecución, velocidad y datos.
Y es aquí donde China entra en juego.
Los empresarios chinos que financio como inversor de riesgo,
son trabajadores increíbles,
con una ética de trabajo impecable.
Mi ejemplo de la sala de partos no es comparable
con lo duro que se trabaja en China.
Por ejemplo, una compañía promovía equilibrio entre trabajo y vida personal:
"Ven a trabajar con nosotros que somos 996".
¿Y esto qué significa?
Significa que el trabajo es de las 9 a.m. hasta las 9 p.m., seis días a la semana.
Esto contrastaba con otras empresas que eran 997.
Y la calidad de los productos chinos ha mejorado consistentemente
en la ultima década,
y eso es debido al ambiente intensamente competitivo.
En Silicon Valley los empresarios compiten de forma caballeresca,
algo así como las guerras antiguas cuando se tomaba turnos
para dispararse entre ellos.
(Risas)
Pero en el ambiente chino,
es realmente un lucha de gladiadores hasta la muerte.
En un ambiente tan brutal, los empresarios aprenden a crecer rápidamente,
a mejorar sus productos a la velocidad del rayo
y a refinar sus modelos de negocios
hasta ser inexpugnables.
Como resultado, productos chinos como WeChat y Weibo,
son sin duda mejores que sus equivalentes occidentales de Facebook y Twitter.
Y el mercado chino adopta este cambio
y acelera los cambios de paradigmas.
Por ejemplo, si alguno de Uds. visita China,
se dará cuenta que casi no se usa
el dinero en efectivo o las tarjetas de crédito,
porque los pagos vía móvil de los que todos hablan
son una realidad en China.
En el último año,
USD 18.8 billones se han realizado en transacciones móviles,
todo gracias a las robustas tecnologías
sobre las que se construyen.
Esta cifra es aun mayor que el PIB de China.
¿cómo pueden ser estas tecnologías aun mayores que el PIB?
Porque incluyen todas las transacciones:
Ventas al mayor, al menor, en línea, en vías especializadas,
en el centro comercial o en el mercado también.
La tecnología la usan más de 700 millones de personas
que hacen pagos entre ellas, no solo comerciantes,
es de igual a igual,
y casi sin cobros por transacción.
Es instantáneo,
y se puede usar donde sea.
Como punto final, el mercado en China es enorme.
El mercado es gigante,
lo que ayuda a los empresarios a tener más usuarios, más ingresos,
más inversiones y lo más importante,
le da a las empresas la oportunidad de recolectar grandes masas de datos
lo cual se convierten en combustible para los motores de IAs.
Como resultado, las empresas de IA chinas
han dado un paso adelante.
Por eso hoy en día, las empresas más importantes
en el campo de la visión artificial, reconocimiento del habla,
sintetizadores de voz, traducción automática y drones
son todas de origen chino.
Con EE. UU. al frente de la era del descubrimiento
y China al frente de la era de la implementación,
ahora vivimos en una era increíble.
Donde la fuerza de dos grandes superpotencias
trabajan conjuntamente
para llevar a cabo la revolución tecnológica más veloz
que jamás haya visto la humanidad.
Esto traerá grandes riquezas.
Riquezas sin precedentes:
USD 16 billones, según PwC
en términos de PIB añadido al PIB del mundo para el año 2030.
Pero también traerá inmensos desafíos
en cómo se reemplazan diversas áreas del trabajo.
Mientras que en la era industrial
se crearon más puestos de trabajo
debido a que toda la producción fue separada en la línea de ensamble
y se crearon nuevos puestos de trabajo.
Pero las IAs reemplazan los trabajos individuales
en la línea de ensamble por robots.
Y esto no está limitado a las fábricas,
los choferes de autobuses y autos,
áreas como las televentas, atención al cliente,
hematólogos y hasta radiólogos,
dentro de 15 años
serán reemplazados de forma gradual
por inteligencias artificiales.
Y solo los trabajos de creatividad...
(Risas)
Tengo que proteger mi puesto, ¿no?
La verdad es que los trabajos creativos estarán seguros
porque si bien las IAs pueden optimizar, no pueden llegar a crear.
Pero existe algo más serio que la pérdida de puestos de trabajo
y es la pérdida de significado,
debido a que la ética de trabajo en la era industrial
nos ha llevado a creer que el trabajo es nuestra razón para existir,
que el trabajo define el significado de nuestras vidas.
Y debo de admitir que yo era un ejemplo vivo de esa mentalidad de trabajo.
Trabajaba muchísimo.
Y es por eso que casi dejo a mi mujer abandonada en la sala de partos,
es por eso que trabajaba en 996 junto a varios de mis colegas,
y esa obsesión que tenía con el trabajo
terminó de forma súbita hace unos años
cuando fui diagnosticado con un linfoma muy avanzado.
Los escáneres de TEP mostraban más de 20 tumores malignos
rebotando como si fuesen bolas de fuego,
acabando con toda mi ambición.
Pero lo más importante es que
me ayudó a reevaluar mi vida.
Saber que tal vez solo tendría unos cuantos meses de vida
me hizo darme cuenta lo tonto que fui
al basar toda mi autoestima
en lo duro que trabajaba y en los logros del trabajo.
Mis prioridades estaban totalmente desordenadas.
Había abandonado a mi familia.
Mi padre había fallecido
y nunca me di la oportunidad de decirle lo mucho que le quería.
Mi madre sufría de demencia y ya no era capaz de reconocerme,
y mis hijos crecieron sin mí.
Durante mi quimioterapia,
leí un libro de Bronnie Ware
acerca de los últimos deseos y arrepentimientos de la gente moribunda.
Ella descubrió que, al enfrentarse a la muerte,
nadie lamentó no haber trabajado más durante su vida.
Solo lamentaban no haber pasado más tiempo con sus seres queridos
y que no repartieron su amor.
Por fortuna, actualmente estoy en remisión.
(Aplausos)
Así que puedo estar de vuelta en TED
y compartir con Uds. que he cambiado.
Ahora solo trabajo 965 --
ocasionalmente 996, pero por lo general, 965.
Me mudé más cerca de mi madre,
mi esposa suele viajar conmigo,
y cuando mis hijos están de vacaciones voy a visitarlos, si ellos no me visitan.
Es una nueva forma de vivir.
Una que me ayudó a reconocer
lo importante que es el amor para mí,
y el estar al borde de la muerte me ayudó a cambiar mi vida,
pero tambien me ayudó a ver una nueva forma
en la que la IA debería impactar a la humanidad,
al trabajo y coexistir con nosotros.
La realidad es que la IA está tomando muchos trabajos rutinarios,
pero los trabajos rutinarios no son nuestra razón de ser.
Nuestra razón de ser es el amor.
Cuando tenemos en brazos a nuestro recién nacido,
amamos a primera vista,
o cuando ayudamos a alguien que necesita ayuda.
El humano es el único que es capaz de dar y recibir amor,
y eso es lo que nos hace diferentes a la IA.
Y a pesar de lo que diga la ciencia ficción,
les puedo asegurar que la IA no siente amor.
Cuando AlphaGo venció al campeón mundial Ke Jie,
Ke Jie lloraba y amaba el juego Go,
mientras que AlphaGo no sintió nada al haber ganado
y, ciertamente, tampoco sentía deseos de abrazar a algún ser querido.
¿Cómo nos diferenciamos
como humanos en la era de la IA?
Ya hablamos del eje de la creatividad,
y definitivamente es una posibilidad,
y ahora introducimos un nuevo eje,
uno que podamos llamar amor, compasión o empatía.
Estas son cosas que las IAs no pueden hacer.
Mientras que las IAs se hacen cargo de los trabajos rutinarios,
me gusta pensar que deberíamos crear trabajos de compasión.
Seguro preguntarán cuántos trabajos de esos existen,
pero yo les pregunto:
¿No creen que necesitaremos muchos trabajadores sociales
para hacer esta transición?
¿No creen que harán falta más enfermeros empáticos
para dar asistencia médica a toda la gente?
¿No creen que necesitaremos 10 veces más profesores
para guiar a nuestros niños a que encuentren su vocación,
y tengan éxito en este mundo del mañana?
Y con toda las nuevas riquezas,
¿no deberíamos convertir nuestras labores de amor en carreras reconocidas
y hacer que el cuidado a los mayores
y la educación escolar en casa también sean carreras valoradas?
(Aplausos)
Esta gráfica puede que no sea perfecta,
pero deja en claro los cuatro puntos sobre los que podemos trabajar con las IAs.
Las IAs asumirán los trabajos rutinarios
y con el tiempo estaremos agradecidos que sea así.
Las IAs se convertirán en grandes herramientas para los creativos.
Así científicos, artistas, músicos y escritores
podrán ser aún más creativos.
Las IAs trabajarán con la humanidad como herramientas de análisis
para que el humano pueda envolver con su calor
los trabajos de alta empatía.
Y siempre podemos ser diferentes
con empleos de corte único
que sean creativos y empáticos a la vez,
usando y aprovechándonos de nuestros irreemplazables cerebros y corazones.
Así que ahí lo tienen:
un mapa para la coexistencia del humano y las IAs.
La IA es una serendipia.
Está aquí para liberarnos de nuestros trabajos rutinarios
y esta aquí para recordarnos que es lo que nos hace humanos.
Escojamos aprovechar la IA y amarnos mutuamente.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)